So we've talked about push and pull queues now. But
what if you just want to do something at regular intervals?
For example, perform a backup, remove temporary files or send a
daily report at midnight every day. That's exactly what a Cron
job does. It's a scheduler. An app engine cron job
is very similar to a cron job in Unix, if you
have worked with that. So, cron is a scheduler within app
engine that allows you to specify tasks that are executed regularly.
Cron is perfect to use to perform background tasks, which
are not directly initiated from user activity. For example, to
run batch or synchronization jobs of different kinds and back
ups, etc. The cron job is very easy to configure
and there are two things you need to specify. First
of all, the URL that should be called. This is
where you place the code you want to execute and
then you also need to specify the schedule which controls
when the task URL is called and as with the Queues there is a ten minute
limit for dynamic instances. If you want more
time than that, you can use resident instances.